et pour en parler nous sommes avec
emmanuel dupuy président de l'institut
prospective et sécurité bonjour et merci
d'être avec nous donald trump évoque
donc un deal du siècle un plan qui a été
préparé ces trois dernières années on le
rappelle quel est votre regard sont pas
écoutés quand il s'agit d'un plan ou en
tout cas au niveau qu'en inde il il faut
que tous les partis soit associée on a
bien vu que lors de la présentation de
ce plan il y avait un grand absent ou
plutôt plusieurs absents en l'occurrence
la position palestinienne qui s'est
exprimée déjà en amont et qui a confirmé
le fait qu'elle ne pensait pas que
c'était un plan qui était équilibré
juste en tout cas c'est un plan qui
remet en cause la totalité des
précédentes tentatives de négocier une
solution à deux états d'ailleurs l'onu
et un certain nombre de grands
partenaires diplomatiques qui s'était
impliqué sur cette question ont rappelé
le droit international la résolution 242
c'est à dire le statut de l'occupation
des territoires conquis par israël en
1967 est évidemment la mobilisation
depuis les accords d'oslo pour la
solution à deux états qui évidemment
s'éloigne un peu par rapport à ce que on
a entendu de la présentation hier de ce
plan ce plan n'est pas encore validé
doit être présenté à la knesset dimanche
prochain et on est en attente d'une
réunion de la ligue arabe qui va
évidemment essayer d'harmoniser les
positions des pays voisins
il ya d'ailleurs un pays voisin qui
s'est déjà exprimée c'est la jordanie
qui est particulièrement les et dans ce
projet puisque la vallée du jourdain lui
échappe alors même que c'était une des
conditions qui avaient permis le
rétablissement des relations
diplomatiques en 93
alors justement pour que les choses
soient soit bien clair dans l'esprit de
tous concrètement qu'est-ce qu'il va
changer ce plan s'il est approuvé c'est
compliqué au niveau de la région comment
est-ce que les choses vont se mettre en
place a déjà ce plan consacre d'une
certaine façon une bascule de soutien
vers israël qui n'étaient pas présents
jusqu'à présent l'arabie saoudite par le
biais du prince héritier maha ben
mohamed ben salmane avait dit il y a de
cela quelques semaines à l'occasion
quelques mois pardon à l'occasion d'un
déplacement à washington qu'il allait
soutenir ce plan
que in fine et la demande palestinienne
d'une capitale pouvait basculer de
jérusalem est à l'est de jérusalem est
je dis cela parce que lors de la
présentation ce n'était pas très clair
dans l'âme de l'aveu même du président
américain de savoir si jérusalem est et
la capitale une et indivisible pardon de
l'état de l'état israélien ou que
c'était une capitale qui devait être
séquencés entre jerusalem - un côté
jérusalem est donc il ya sans doute une
opposition de rupture d'un certain
nombre de pays qui jusqu'à présent
soutenait ardemment la position de la
solution à deux états est évidemment
l'unanimité où les divergences qui
risquent d'apparaître à la ligue arabe
vont peut-être conforter la position
israélienne sur l'esprit dans l'esprit
pardon d'une nouvelle thématique qui est
celle d'une mobilisation des pays arabes
ou en tout cas des pays du golfe contre
l'iran qui d'une certaine façon un autre
deal qui sous-tend la présentation du
projet américain
le président justement américain donald
trump a évoqué un plan réaliste à deux
états est ce que 2 est assez réaliste
selon vos os donald trump met en avant
une occasion gagnant-gagnant 67 ans
c'est compliqué de parler d'une solution
à deux états quand une bonne partie du
territoire palestinien et se trouve
tronquée plus de 40% du territoire
palestiniens de la cisjordanie va
basculer vers israël la reconnaissance
implicite d'ailleurs qu'ils avaient été
induites par l'édition américaine de
reconnaître
contrairement au droit international la
colonisation des quelques centaines de
colonies qui qui regroupe pardon plus de
400 à 500 mille palestiniens des
châteaux va être reconnu d'ailleurs ça
ne la décision américaine n'a pas tardé
puisque l'ambassadeur américain à
jérusalem a d'ores et déjà dit que le
délai de carence qui étaient inscrits
dans le deal du siècle pouvait être
abrogée et que la colonisation pouvait
reprendre en tout cas remettant en cause
de droit international
donc je ne suis pas certain que les
palestiniens y gagne les palestiniens et
gagne un état dont la souveraineté ne
sera pas garanti par la communauté
internationale avec bien évidemment la
difficulté d'avoir un état qui n'aura
pas d'armé et bien évidemment tu n'auras
pas le contrôle
de sa souveraineté aérienne par exemple
comment est ce qu'aujourd'hui on fait
accepter un plan aux palestiniens qui
n'ont pas été vraiment convié qui n'ont
pas participé aux discussions
ça va être choses assez compliquées a
écrit tellement on est loin très très
loin de désaccord comme david en 1978
est encore plus loin des accords d'oslo
1993 au cours duquel évidemment les deux
parties étaient associés sous l'égide
des états unis ouvre par exemple de la
conférence de madrid avec la russie et
les etats unis parce qu'on le rappelle
le le dialogue a été rompu entre les
palestiniens depuis que washington a
reconnu jérusalem comme capitale
d'israël
il n'y a plus aucun échange d'un du malt
caramel mahmoud abbas a été très clair
en disant que la solution qu'il ne
visait pas évidemment à une position
d'équilibré c'est à dire que les états
unis où la communauté internationale
pouvait agir comme un partenaire otoka
médiateur évidemment oblige la police
tin et ça a été redit à l'occasion
d'ailleurs du déplacement de plusieurs
chefs d'état de gouvernement qui se sont
rendus à ramallah pour rencontrer
mahmoud abbas à l'occasion des
cérémonies d'anniversaire de la
libération des camps qu'effectivement
les palestiniens se chercher un autre
interlocuteur
peut-être que ce sera la russie en tout
cas la position française la position
allemande la position européenne est
conforme à la tradition diplomatique qui
fait qu effectivement maintenant les
quelque 226 résolution onusienne doit
être respectée et bien évidemment la
solution à deux états a été ardemment
négocier jusqu'à présent avec ce plan p
on a une autre solution diplomatique en
tout cas une autre méthodologie du pot
matif alors les réactions sont
évidemment nombreuses notamment du côté
palestinien le premier ministre
palestinien a déclaré
que ce n'était pas un plan de paix pour
le moyen-orient il a jugé que cette
initiative visait avant tout à protéger
je le cite à protéger trucks de la
destitution et netanyahu de la prison
for contextualiser aussi à la
présentation de ce plan fait alors c'est
un cadeau effectivement fait à benjamin
et à l'est ou d'ailleurs le président
américain a essayé de diluer ce cadeau
en invitant son opposant mais ils
gagnent ce qui n'a pas voulu être
accueillis ou en tout cas n'a pas voulu
rencontrer avec le président américain
le l'actuel premier ministre benjamin
netanyahu mais d'une certaine façon
évidemment la présentation d'un plan
paix en présence du premier ministre
avec évidemment tous ceux qui avaient
négocié se planter je pense notamment à
jared kushner confirme le fait qu'il ya
sans doute une sorte de jeu n'est pas
une imposition mais en tout cas une
forte pression de la part des américains
est d'ailleurs en paraphrasant le
président américain que le plan de paix
soit accepter ou pas peu importe les
américains essayent d'apporter leur
garantie en n'oubliant pas un point
important c'est que le financement de ce
plan de paix ne sera pas assurée par les
américains mais par les partenaires on
parle de 50 milliards de dollars
et là aussi il faut voir quels seront
les pays qui soutiendront ou pas ce plan
de paix merci beaucoup pour votre
analyse emmanuel dupuy je rappelle que
vous êtes président de l'institut et
prospective et sécurité